The late 1960s saw two nations, Britain and France, bet everything on a dream.
Not just any dream, but one that would rewrite the rules of travel, of speed, of human ambition.
They called it the Concord, a bird of steel, a needle piercing the sky,
capable of carrying passengers across the Atlantic in less than half the time it took before.
It was supposed to be the future, and for a while, it was.
The governments poured money into it like water into a bottomless well.
Engineers worked miracles. Politicians spoke of revolution.
The world watched in awe as this magnificent machine took flight.
And yet here's a thing. No one ever asked the simplest question.
Could this actually make money?
The answer, of course, was no.
But by then it didn't matter. Too much had already been spent.
Too many careers, too many reputations, too many years were tied to that gleaming supersonic egg.
So they kept pouring. And pouring. And pouring.
This, my friends, is what behavioral economists later dubbed the Concord fallacy.
The moment you've invested enough time, pride, or cash you can't stop,
even when the math screams at you to walk away,
the Concord wasn't just a plane.
It was a trap.
And it became the patron saint of what I like to call vapid goals.
Now, let me tell you about the ambition trap.
You've probably heard the advice, set SMART goals.
Specific. Measurable. Achievable. Relevant. Time-bound.
It's the kind of thing they teach you in motivational seminars,
in self-help books,
in the quiet moments between scrolling through your phone,
and it's terrible for misery.
Because here's the secret. Success provides closure.
And closure is the enemy of the slow, delicious rot of unfulfilled potential.
So, if you want to stay miserable, truly miserable,
you don't set SMART goals.
You set VAPID ones.
The moment you declare a goal that's impossible,
you get a rush.
A dopamine hit.
You feel like the kind of person who COULD do it.
And then, nothing.
Because the goal was never real.
It was never meant to be reached.
You spend your life in the planning stage,
forever fueled by the thrill of a new beginning,
forever crushed by the weight of what's coming.
Heh.
Let's break it down.
First, make it vague.
Don't say, I want to run a 5K.
Say, I want to be a person of vitality.
See the difference?
With the first, you know exactly what failure looks like.
With the second, you can't even define it.
And that means the anxiety never goes away.
You're always not there yet.
Always a failure.
Always just trying.
Then, make it amorphous.
No milestones.
No progress bars.
No way to measure if you're getting closer.
You're either in the game or you're not.
And since you're never actually winning,
you're always in the game.
Always chasing.
Always failing.
Next, make it pointless.
Spend six months learning the accordion while your rent is due.
Write a novel no one will read.
Train for a marathon you'll never run.
The bigger the gap between what you're doing and what actually matters,
the deeper the regret will cut.
Then, make it impossible.
Don't aim for a promotion.
Aim to be the CEO of a company that doesn't exist.
Don't want to lose weight?
Want to be the first human to bench press a skyscraper?
Remember, the wider the chasm between your reality and your dream,
the wider the despair gap will yawn beneath you.
And finally, make it distracting.
Use your vapid goal as a shield.
Your marriage is falling apart?
Perfect.
Take up extreme mountain unicycling.
Your career is a dead end?
No problem.
Start a business selling cloud-based dreams to people who don't know what clouds are.
The more absurd the goal,
the less you have to face the real mess of your life.
The final step.
The Concord Maneuver.
Announce it.
Loudly.
To your friends.
To your family.
To the entire world if you're feeling particularly bold.
Post it on social media.
Make it public.
Because when you inevitably abandon the goal after dropping too grand on unicycling gear,
after six months of accordion lessons,
after realizing you'll never be the CEO of anything,
you don't just fail in private.
You fail spectacularly.
You fail with witnesses.
You fail with a side of public shame,
like a dessert you didn't ask for but can't refuse.
And that, my friend,
is how you turn ambition into a life sentence.
As someone once said,
though I can't remember who,
a goal you can achieve is a goal that can't haunt you.
Aim for the impossible and live in the shadow of your own ambition.
And what a shadow it is.